I got an email from an aerobatic team
that said hi we attached pyrotechnics to
our planes so we can produce a firework
show in mid-flight do you want to come
for a test ride what else are we gonna
say look at that fun fact my inspiration
for era sparks came from seeing New
Year's Eve on television in Edinburgh
where underneath the castle they had a
waterfall of light I wouldn't imagine
that being somehow trading off behind
the wing of an aeroplane era spark the
display team we're looking often
privileged enough to go all over the
world we've been to China Saudi Arabia
Portugal lots of locations in Europe and
obviously locations in the UK and we can
display from up to 300,000 people 2
million people all right it is nearly
dark enough and our planes are nearly in
position this is gonna happen very soon
just be clear this is a practice run
this is not a proper display when
there's a display there is a lot more
going on the cockpit a lot more girl on
the pyrotechnics and there are very much
not allowed to take passengers but one
of the big waves is flying extremely
close formation
we're helped by the wings being
extremely long so your peripheral vision
is just full of aeroplanes I don't see
God very often but I know that he's
probably only three meters from my
aircraft and that's where trust comes in
you'll see us firing lots of different
kinds of fireworks pyro from the
aeroplanes they all need preparation and
that can take some hours so all of the
igniters the e matches need inserting
into the fireworks we need to work out
what we're going to put on the aeroplane
wear and then the process of actually
fitting with the airplane again can take
half now - now we genuinely can't shimmy
down the wing and like the blue touch
paper all commercial firework displays
are ignited the same way they're all
knighted with a control box lighting an
e match or an igniter and that goes into
the blue
pay for effectively and we do just the
same we started out by having a bank of
switches but when you're under high
workload in formation flying it's so
easy to hit the wrong button we can fire
24 separate fireworks in our display you
can't get 24 right in a sequence so
we've actually had a bespoke computer
system designed it not only does it fire
our fireworks for us but it also it
controls the LED light system on the
airplanes as well and that means I now
have only one button so once I pressed
it once then auto sequences on to the
next part of the programs my imagination
I found over the years has always been
the cup leapfrog ahead of the
authorities regulation not trying to
stop what we're doing but trying to
understand what we're doing and finding
out where it fits into regulations that
were written quite genuinely not for
aeroplanes so at the moment we're
dealing with aviation regulation and
firework regulation
[Applause]
Thank You Phoebe Ross Phoebe so the
question is how can they do this and how
can they do this safely we have defined
roles my job is to lead the formation
lead the display rob is working very
hard to climb out working out exactly
where to start a display and how to
modify the display subtly to keep it in
the right place with the wind conditions
and my job is very clear to fly safely
and as close as I can without hitting
him planning is everything in our
display and that planning starts on the
ground before we even get airborne we do
a bumblebee dance as we call it so we go
round in circles in our mind and
physically mimicking the manoeuvres that
we're then go do in the sky and that
then sets a cadence and a rhythm and a
physical memory of what you're doing so
that when we start a display we're on
the same page and working as a team on
the radio we're confirming all the time
what we're going to do before we do it
[Music]
our choice is using a broad y9 motor
glider was for lots of reasons one of my
original imaginations of this firework
display was to separate the fireworks as
far as we could and we need a big
wingspan for that because it's a glider
it also has efficiency of a glider which
means that we can perform aerobatics
with a very small engine and it gives us
grace the disadvantage with a motor
glider is a very small engine that means
we take a long time to climb altitude
and when as how's the tube we try and
conserve all the energy we have we
describe our display as painting with
light we like to think that the focus is
more on the image we're painting with
the airplanes rather the distinct
maneuvers were doing separately
fireworks are great on the ground when
you're flying next to fireworks is even
better and I still pinch myself every
time I even think about going flying
with fireworks and just think I can't
believe we're actually gonna do this
that's incredible so that's that's what
QK now and what do you do in flora
tomorrow will be twice as much pyro in
the same length of time there is gonna
be Armageddon thank you so so much
are you you can find out more about
arrow sparks and obvious way they're
going to put the link at the description
thank you ah what we are going to do is
the internal oh and lands a glider okay
um sure
air although their engine just stopped
you